foreign
is a concept called evolvability what is
it about things that allows them to
evolve
why do things evolve at all
how can we measure this property can you
increase or decrease the evolvability of
something so take a microbe take a
bacteria that's evolving to be resistant
to an antibiotic which is one of the
things that I focus on we're trying to
figure out what are the things inside of
a cell that actually influence how
Evolution happens
by working with faculty in the
Department of Chemistry we're able to
look at that at a chemical biological
scale we're able to merge that with my
perspective which is more of an
evolutionary scale and I put that
together towards like an integrated
theory of evolvability that we can apply
broadly using that both to understand
how Evolution happens and potentially
use that understanding for a better drug
treatments for certain diseases trying
to leverage our understanding of
evolutionary biology to better inform
how we deal with the major Public Health
crisis of drug resistance
my name is Brandon obunu I'm a visiting
assistant professor in the Department of
Chemistry in the Martin Luther King Jr
visiting Scholars Program when I think
about kind of making science more
inclusive and diversifying science I
think that's core to my identity as an
academic and a thinker and I think the
reason for that is I want access to the
best ideas in the world and I want to
produce the best ideas in the world with
the best people the only way that can
happen is if everyone has access to this
scientific Enterprise
and then of course there's like a very
personal part of this story as well and
I was raised by a single mother a single
African-American woman who is the one
who raised me to be a scientist and I
think she was a school teacher which is
about as far as that demographic went in
her day and I always say that she would
have been a better scientist than I am
had she gotten the opportunities that
I've been given so that's you know a
type of a burden for me and I feel like
I have to do what I can to try to
include as many people like my mother in
the scientific Enterprise
[Music]
foreign